c'est à
9h1 que on a pris cette libération hier
soir et on y voit un peu plus clair
aujourd'hui sur l'opération de l'armée
colombienne une opération digne d'un
film a indiqué le ministre de la Défense
explication Arnaud
Boutet lorsque les deux hélicoptères
quittent la jungle de guaviaré leurs
occupants viennent de réaliser un coup
de bluff sans tirer le moindre coup de
feu l'opération digne d'un film commence
des mois plus tôt des militaires col
bien infiltre les farques jusqu'au
commandement ils localisent les otages
importants et font croire que leur chef
exige le regroupement hier jour J celui
de l'intervention les faux hélicoptères
de l'armée sont repints en blanc et les
soldats déguisés en
guérriéros j'ai vu qu'ils avaient des
T-shirts de
cheegevara je me suis dit c'est des
FARC ils nous ont dit vous pouvez monter
dans
l'hélicoptère mais seulement avec des
menottes ça a été très humiliant ils ont
fermé les portes de
l'hélicoptère on a décollé et là il
s'est passé quelque
chose je n'ai pas compris tout de
suite j'ai vu le commandant des FARC qui
pendant tant d'années si souvent s'est
révélé un véritable
despote je l'ai vu ligé devant moi dans
l'élico quelques minutes plus tard
libérateur tombe le
masque le chef de l'opération a dit nous
sommes l'armée nationale vous êtes
libre et l'hélicoptère a failli tomber
tellement SAÉ de joie on pleurait on
s'embrasser on apprend aussi que les
Français avaient engagé de leur côté une
négociation humanitaire avec les farces
ils avaient même localisé une gr bê
encour et la savait en bonne santé
l'action colombienne s'est révélé plus
rapide et surtout plus efficace bon
c'est à
9h1 que on a pris cette libération hier
soir et on y voit un peu plus clair
aujourd'hui sur l'opération de l'armée
colombienne une opération digne d'un
film a indiqué le ministre de la Défense
explication Arnaud
Boutet lorsque les deux hélicoptères
quittent la jungle de guaviaré leurs
occupants viennent de réaliser un coup
de bluff sans tirer le moindre coup de
feu l'opération digne d'un film commence
des mois plus tôt des militaires
colombiens infiltrent les farques
jusqu'au commandement ils localisent les
otages importants et font croire que
leur chef exige le regroupement hier
jour J celui de l'intervention les faux
hélicoptères de l'armée sont repints en
blanc et les soldat déguisés en
guériéros j'ai vu qu'ils avaient des
T-shirts de
che je me suis dit c'est des
FARC ils nous ont dit vous pouvez monter
dans hélicoptère mais seulement avec des
menotes ça étit très humiliant ils ont
fermé les portes de
l'hélicoptère on a décollé et là il
s'est passé quelque
chose je n'ai pas compris tout de
suite j'ai vu le commandant des FARC qui
pendant tant d'années si souvent s'est
révélé un véritable
despote je l'ai vu ligoter devant moi
dans
l'élico
quelques minutes plus tard les
libérateurs tombent le
masque le chef de l'opération a dit nous
sommes l'armée nationale vous êes
libre l'hélicoptère a fa tomber
tellement de
Jo Oni que les Français engagé de leur
côté une négociation humanitaire les il
localisour et la B
santé s révélé plus rapide et surtout
plus
efficace